welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and have we been living in a Marvel
Cinematic Matrix in which the Scarlet
Witch erased the X-men with the X-Men
set to make their mutant homecoming to
the MCU this year in Deadpool 3 it seems
like Marvel's Multiverse Saga is just
going to use well the Multiverse to
establish mutants in this franchise so
when we ask where have the X-Men been
the answer could just be they've been in
a separate universe but in order to say
merging the fox era X-Men continuity
cast into this MCU through some
multiversal incursion event and just
leave it at that would mean that the
studio would plan to stick with Hugh
Jackman Patrick Stewart Ian McKellen
Kelsey gramar all those old guys for the
Long Haul and I love those guys but I
just don't see guys that age being
Marvel Studios X-Men lineup for the
future like what I assume will be their
mutant Saga on the other side of Secret
Wars so there has got to be some other
explanation of how we get mutants and
X-Men in the MCU like beyond what
they're already planning for the
animated X-Men 97 but maybe following
that road map but also a plan that
doesn't rewrite or negate the MCU
Infinity Saga history that we've known
in love like we still want to be able to
watch Ironman and be like yeah it's all
still connected so in this video let's
talk about the theory that the X-Men
were supposed to have existed in the MCU
continuity but that at some point in the
past Wanda maximoff warped and rewrote
reality to erase them from existence
that in the MCU we have been living a
lie inside of a broken Matrix where
everyone has forgotten mutants existed I
know that we've discussed this theory on
the new rock stars channel before
probably in a number of w division after
shows that have blacked out and I know
for sure a number of Theory videos over
the years and I know that I'm not the
only person to ask this question or to
theorize that the MCU we know is a post
house ofm no more mutants reality but my
goal here is to just look at the new
things we've learned about the MCU like
from the more recent Marvel titles
details and research from our latest 24
Xmen stick snake rewatch and just
connecting the dots in a new way that I
don't think we have before so let's
revisit the question did Wanda erase the
X-Men okay two ground rules here one
let's try to do this without a
multiversal reset explanation that
involves incursions from other realities
just as part of an intellectual exercise
but also so that we can still live in an
MCU where there was both a Robert Dy
junr Tony Stark and Xmen at some point
in history let's see if we can figure
that out in second rule let's try to
maintain what we like about the infinity
Saga and the X-Men and not do something
that'll piss everyone off like force a
new origin story for Magneto where he
wasn't a holocaust Survivor trust me you
don't want to erase that and I bring
this up because that would rule out any
explanation that like thanos's Snap
radiation could have created mutants in
the MCU because that would mean that the
MCU Magneto origin story would have to
be like in the present day not in the
1940s but since the MCU present day is
like 2025 and Beyond I think we're just
going to have to accept that Magneto is
going to have to be old and maybe it
could just be that mutants like the
Wizards of Harry Potter live longer
average lifespans like say 120 years
instead of 80 years because you know
they are more evolved humans okay an
important thing to know and what I
didn't know until recently is that Kevin
feige from the beginning intended his
MCU at least at the beginning to keep
the door open to team ups with the X-Men
and mutant characters from 2000 to 2006
Kevin feige had a hand in producing all
Prem MCU Marvel titles and at the time
he didn't really see much of a legal
division among those properties they
were all part of a potentially shared
Universe from 2006 to 2010 Kevin figes
Marvel Studios was an independent Studio
they partnered with anybody they
partnered with Paramount for Iron Man 1
two for Captain America for Thor and
then they partnered with universal for
the 2008 Incredible Hulk film Kevin
feige was open to working again with Fox
for an X-Men team up with his Marvel
characters or with Sony for a Spider-Man
team up and for Spider-Man he absolutely
did that with Amy Pascal in 2014 for a
Spider-Man MCU reboot it was just that
in those early years fige was more
focused on characters Marvel owned
outright and wouldn't have to share
which included Iron Man Captain America
Thor and the Avengers but to legitimize
these characters in the eyes of viewers
fige wanted to present them as
characters who could exist alongside
bigger names like the X-Men that is why
Bay one of the MCU and most years after
that didn't really set any of their
stories in the Years 2000 to 2008 it's
kind of like a big gap in the MCU
historical record where Kevin feige
didn't really plant any flags and I
think initially he did that to keep the
option open of saying that those Fox
X-Men films that were set in the mid and
early ATS as part of a shared history
with what he was building and we have
proof that this was the intent because
when John favro and Kevin feige shot
Iron Man their original post credit
scene with Nick Fury had him saying a
different line as if gamma accidents
radioactive bug bites and assorted
mutants weren't enough assorted mutants
they ended up cutting this line because
they didn't want to run into some rights
issues that were starting to Bubble Up
but you can tell creatively that was
part of his vision 2009's X-Men Origins
Wolverine established that Wolverine was
Weapon X as in the 10th super soldier
experiment that true to the comics began
with Captain America Steve Rogers weapon
one around around this time Marvel
Studios was partnering with Paramount to
produce the first Captain America film
and they considered in this movie cameos
from James howlet Wolverine and Eric
lyncher Young Magneto during Steve
Rogers exploits on the battlefield in
World War II also X-Men Origins
Wolverine included a scene where Striker
team X goes to Nigeria to recover ore
from a meteorite hinted to be vibranium
because Striker uses that ore to create
adamantium and again this came out
around when they were shooting the scene
where Howard Stark was presenting Steve
Rogers with a vibranium shield in the
1940s and in the 2008 Hulk film the
origins of the Hulk and of abomination
were established to be a part of the
same super soldier program history that
Steve Rogers was a part of and that by
extension Wolverine was a part of it too
that's why on that tank that thus Ross
finds is mentioned Dr ERS Skin's Alias
and Vitas it was all going to be part of
the same government program the pieces
were all there in case Kevin feige ever
had the ability to connect them the idea
was that the MCU early years could share
that continuity with the fox X-Men
because why not what would be the harm
in keeping that door open at least that
change when Marvel Studios sold to
Disney on December 31st 2009 a deal that
really started to go into effect in 2010
with all the Productions that started
happening after that so any future
collaborations with Fox at least in the
short term were now off the table
because Fox and Disney were then rival
Studios so Marvel Studios as a Disney
subsidiary had to figure out a way to
move forward and to build a Marvel
Universe without X-Men in it and it was
awkward and difficult part of the plan
at the time was using versions of these
characters without referencing their
mutant backstory so while building up to
2015's Avengers of Voltron they
introduced the maximoff twins in the
post-edit scene of 2014's Captain
America Winter Soldier this came after a
dispute between Disney and fox over the
rights to these two characters and it
was settled in an agreement in which the
fox films could make their own version
of quicksilver that wouldn't reference
The Avengers and that Marvel could have
their version of Quicksilver and Scarlet
witch that just didn't reference them as
mutants or children of Magneto and so in
the Age of Ultron film director Jos
Sweden got around this by using the code
word of enhanced to describe these twins
we have an enhanced in the field so
basic basically Jos Sweden created this
sort of elseworld reality that awkwardly
danced around the fact that X-Men didn't
exist in it for the first time the MCU
started to feel a little incomplete and
that's why around this time Marvel fans
started to invent this backstory that
Kevin feige once described this as Earth
199999 but really that came from like an
MCU reference book in 2008 they can't F
get nothing to do with but in their eyes
they just didn't want to call it 616
because it felt so different from the
616 Comics this video is sponsored by
pork bun.com pork bun.com is a domain
name regar that makes getting your own
domain name EAS easy and affordable pork
bun.com has the lowest price on hundreds
of different domain extensions things
like.xyz proo so you can create a
website to show off what you do with a
name that's memorable unique and
perfectly suited to you every domain
name at pork bun comes with tons of
freebies like SSL certificates who is
privacy DNS and URL forwarding stuff
that other domain regist charge for
they've also got free trials for their
link and bio tool that makes it easy to
keep the links to all your Platforms in
one place plus web and email hosting
trials BBN also has a chat gbt powered
AI generated Search tool that's changing
how people search for domain names all
these features and tools are backed by
incredible support 365 days a year and
more fstar reviews on trust pilot from
real customers than anyone else pork bun
is easy to use and navigate so you can
manage everything about your new domain
name in one place plus they're not
trying to constantly upsell you like
those other places do so you're not
being pressured to pay for products that
you'll never use click the link in the
description below and use code new
rockstars to get $1 off your next domain
name from pork fund.com and build your
online identity so this fear of the
mutant word would change years later
when Disney bought Fox's film and TV
properties outright the Wanda Division
Series in 2021 still didn't Define Wanda
as a mutant just a twin born in 1989 in
war torn sovia watching sitcom DVDs when
a stark Warhead killed her parents and
she used a hex to save it off followed
by her in Petro volunteering for Hydra
and allowing experimentation with the
mindstone that Amplified their powers
with Cosmic radiation but W division did
tip their hat to the X-men with a cameo
by Evan peters's Petro Evan Peters being
the quick silver from the fox X-Men
films and Marvel finally used mutant and
M Marvel for Kamala Khan and black
panther Wana forever for Neymar and of
course we've seen cameos from Patrick
Stewart Professor X and Kelsey gramer
beast but those were in other universes
but let us imagine that the X-Men did
exist in the MCU within its history that
in the years before Tony Stark declared
I am Iron Man the world in which these
characters had been living in was
actually marked by conflicts with mutant
kind not what we saw in the fox X-Men
movies but imagine something closer to a
liveaction X-Men '97 like a 1990s and
early 2000s with a government hunting
mutants with Sentinels various mutant
registration efforts conflicts between
the X-Men and the mutant Brotherhood
other villains like Magneto and Mr
Sinister and apocalypse all making moves
what Nick Fury would have called
assorted mutants when he came to ask
Tony Stark for help perhaps in this
reality the Stark family actually
manufactured Sentinels in that civil
conflict in sovia in 1999 outside the
maximoff's window was a mutant hunt or a
fight over mutant rights perhaps in this
reality there was a real Civil War event
over mutant and superhero registration
and Marvel heroes died either way let's
imagine this world is on fire and so it
is 2014 w maximoff a young mutant is
exposed by Hydro scientists to the
mindstone and in the glow of that Cosmic
radiation she sees her future self as
the Scarlet Witch but she doesn't know
what she's looking at from her point of
view she's Cinderella and this is her
fairy godmother so hoping to end her
suffering from hydra's experiments and
to finally bring an end to the Civil
strip that that is tearing Earth apart
Wanda makes a wish and she says no more
mutants and the future Scarlet Witch
hears her past self and she warps all of
reality in the MCU so that mutants which
are individuals with powers coming from
a mutant X Gene are no longer mutants
and that everyone's memories have been
warped to not remember anything related
to mutant kind as part of their history
but Wanda and Peter would still retain
their powers because they were exposed
to infinity stone radiation that's how
Wanda would still be on that Destiny to
become become the Scarlet Witch but in
this warped reality an X Gene is no
longer activated it just remains dormant
so individuals like Charles Xavier Scott
Summers oror Monroe Hank McCoy Jean Gray
Raven darkholm they're all still living
their lives just as normal humans no
powers James howlet died in the late
19th century Eric luncher sadly might
not have survived the Holocaust
essentially the future Scarlet Witch had
warped everyone's past present and
future to eradicate or just really
deactivate the X Gene throughout all of
history and using the Mind Stone's
Powers covered it all up in a way even
more powerful than Doctor Strange's
Runes of cough call memory spell on
Peter Parker so that in this case no one
remembers mutants existed no one says
the word mutant and even reality is
Warped in various glitches to erase
mutant history from the historical
record and the history Ultron watched
when he woke up was a lie and instead of
mutant related conflicts this reality
warped Matrix that the Scarlet Witch put
us all in is led by an Avengers team
fighting Hydra fighting Ultron fighting
Thanos the MCU that you and I have known
now you may ask would Theos snap have
woken up our reality out of the spell
you know with Wan maximoff Dustin no
because the person who cast this spell
was her future Scarlet Witch self on the
other side of the blip so what happens
to the mutants during the blip well they
aren't mutants anymore they're just
humans half of them dust like everyone
else and 5 years later they come back
and even after Bruce Banner and Tony
Stark both snap the stick stones and
release further blasts of cosmic
radiation life is pretty much back to
normal in the MCU but something spefic
specifically changes with the events of
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness only after this movie do we
start learning of mutants like Kamala
Khan neyar Beast She-Hulk included a
reference to Wolverine existing
somewhere in the MCU now with a headline
rating man with metal claws fights in
bar brawl so really it seems what broke
this no more mutant spell that we're
talking about would be the Scarlet
Witch's death or disappearance whatever
that was in Multiverse of Madness that
red shock wave that we saw as wagor
Mountain crumbled could have been the
reactivation of the mutant Gene
throughout history and throughout the
universe that could be why now suddenly
there is a man with metal claws fighting
in a bar brawl making the news they
don't identify him as Wolverine he is
just a crazy Drifter who doesn't know
where he is and getting in fights if he
has metal claws there now must have been
a weapon x operation in the MCU to give
him that adamantium so I believe the
X-Men exists once more we just haven't
met them yet and that the world just
kind of suffers a general Amnesia postt
trauma to whatever happened before 2014
because it would be one of the many
Justified Mandela effects that the MCU
is experiencing after things like the
snap after a Celestial emerge from the
Indian Ocean no one knows what to
believe right now okay so to recap the
MCU we've been living in is a lie
mutants used to exist alongside the
Avengers Wars with Sentinels and a
passiv war event with the X-Men happened
but in 2014 Wanda wished no more mutants
her future Scarlet Witch self- obliged
reality was warped and now the mutant
Gene is reactivated but everyone is
confused and pretty slow to wake up now
yes I get that Marvel will more likely
do a Multiverse encourage an explanation
but that I believe just works best for
the fox X-Men lineup of actors and on
the other side of that they're going to
have to merge with some other universe
that they're going to have to make up
anyway and I prefer that they just use a
history in which the X-Men in the
infinity Saga history we know were part
of the same history and I guess you
could say oh maybe Kang pruned all the
mutants out of history and now Loki's
letting them back in sure but I just
want to elevate the Scarlet Witch is
importance to the MCU we've been living
in because no more mutants was such a
pivotal moment coming out of House of M
and I want the Scarlet Witch to be the
retroactive mother of the infinity Saga
and hey maybe that upcoming Vision Quest
series could follow white Vision seeking
Wanda out to wake up each of these X-Men
in all of society to what really
happened so that the true X-Men history
could be restored but I want to know
your thoughts on this Theory I know
there's a lot of holes you could poke in
it go for it please like this video And
subscribe to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time
bye